Es ist kurz nach sechs am
Morgen bei Familie Suleiman.
Hast du deine Zähne geputzt?
Nein.
Nein? Immer noch nicht?
Mustafa Suleiman und seine Frau
Abeer machen die vier Kinder
für Kindergarten und Schule fertig.
Ich hab das schon alleine gemacht!
Okay, okay. Alles gut!
Vor fünf Jahren sind die Suleimans
nach Deutschland geflüchtet –
vor dem Krieg aus Syrien.
Mit den beiden Söhnen Joud
und Karam und Tochter Lama.
Der jüngste Sohn Sam ist
in Deutschland geboren.
Sie haben sich das Leben
hier einfacher vorgestellt.
Nach vier Jahren
und unzähligen Umzügen
haben sie nun erstmals
ihre eigene Wohnung.
Langsam verbessert sich unsere Situation
und wir fühlen uns immer wohler.
Aber ich kann noch nicht sagen,
dass es meine neue Heimat ist.
Ich gewöhne mich immer mehr an das Leben
hier und ich verstehe das Land immer besser.
Auf dem Weg zur Schule in Berlin-Spandau.
Gib mir deine Hand, Sami,
wir müssen über die Straße.
Lama geht gerne in die Schule.
Weil ich auch ein bisschen
besser in Mathe bin
und langsam ist es mein
Lieblingsfach geworden.
Schule und Kita – ein Fulltimejob
für Mustafa und Abeer Suleiman.
Sie unterstützen ihre Kinder rund um die Uhr,
damit die Integration in die neue
Sprache und Kultur auch klappt.
Das kostet sie viel Kraft –
nach allem, was sie erlebt haben.
Rückblick:
2015 bereitet Mustafa Suleiman
seine Kinder in der Türkei
auf die Flucht im Schlauchboot
übers Mittelmeer vor.
Über die Balkanroute erreicht die
Familie nach Wochen Deutschland –
festgehalten in einer Reportage
der Deutschen Welle.
Die Flucht und der Krieg haben
Spuren hinterlassen, bis heute.
Mustafa Suleiman wurde bei einem
Bombenangriff verwundet.
Er durchlebt seither Todesängste,
muss regelmäßig in Therapie.
Hallo, Herr Suleiman.
Ja. Hallo.
Guten Tag. Kommen Sie bitte mit?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte Platz, Herr Suleiman?
Heute haben Sie den Termin bei mir,
weil Ihr behandelnder Arzt,
Dr. Tsagkas, ja in Urlaub ist.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Okay, kein Problem.
[Mustafa] Suleimans Mutter ist vor zwei
Wochen in Syrien gestorben.
Dass er nicht bei ihr sein konnte,
quält und zerreißt ihn, erzählt er.
In den letzten Wochen war sie sehr krank und
sie wurde dann ins Krankenhaus gebracht.
Ich habe versucht, mit ihr zu sprechen,
aber sie konnte nicht mehr sprechen und sie
hat mich auch nicht mehr erkannt.
Die Bindung zu seiner Familie ist sehr eng.
Der Vater starb, als Mustafa
Suleiman 14 Jahre war.
Als Ältester hat er früh
Verantwortung übernommen.
Die Mutter zog neun Kinder alleine groß.
Muss ja ’ne starke Frau gewesen sein.
Ja, eine sehr starke Frau, sehr stark.
Herr Suleiman, Sie haben sehr
viele furchtbare Dinge erlebt,
viele Schmerzen ertragen.
Aber ich denke, dass Sie’s
wirklich gut machen jetzt –
in die Zukunft gucken,
in die Zukunft schauen, sich um die Familie,
um Ihre Kinder, um sich selbst kümmern,
aber auch um den Bruder.
Ich denke, das machen Sie wirklich gut.
Und da können Sie auch stolz auf sich sein.
[Mustafa] Suleiman fällt es noch schwer,
seinen Platz in Deutschland zu finden.
Viele Syrer, die er hier kennt, arbeiten
oder haben sich selbständig gemacht.
So wie Ahmad Nanaa:
Er leitet die Filiale eines Restaurants.
Es braucht Zeit, bis sich etwas entwickelt.
Aber Gott sei Dank:
Unser Restaurant ist jetzt sehr bekannt
und hat einen guten Ruf.
Wenn du irgendjemanden fragst,
sagen sie dir:
„Wow! Das Restaurant ist
toll und es läuft gut.“
Jaja, das Restaurant ist
bekannt für das gute Essen.
Und es ist sehr sauber und
als Gast wirst du gut behandelt.
Mustafa Suleiman will bald
auch anfangen zu arbeiten,
doch sein Deutsch muss
noch besser werden.
Das fällt seinen Kindern leichter.
Für sie ist Berlin schon zur Heimat geworden.
Joud will Ingenieur in Berlin werden,
aber sich auch um das Haus
der Familie in Syrien kümmern.
Weil das wurde von einer
Rakete erschossen [getroffen].
Deswegen will ich es mit Papa reparieren.
Mach deine Hand weg! Du liebst nur mich!
Oh, ich liebe euch doch beide,
ich liebe euch alle!